okay let's dive into the content so
today we'll look at flow models it's a
different type of likelihood model
compared to the one we saw last week um
there will be some connections there
will be some differences um it's kind of
interesting because when we taught this
class the previous time spring 2020 flow
models were seeing a big uamp in
popularity um a lot of new results were
coming out but since then as should not
a whole lot of new stuff has come out
almost nothing new has come out um that
could be an opportunity that maybe
people have been missing the right
insights to make them better than they
were four years ago or it could be that
fundamentally there is something that's
not as general about them and so they
don't keep getting better with more data
more compute the way other models have
um I guess we don't know but um it's
something to be aware of if you were to
essentially be a product Builder today
and you're asked to build a product with
a generative model it's very unlikely a
flow model would be your first choice
but as a researcher I think it's really
good to understand how they work what
they can give you and maybe there's
opportunities for improvement or maybe
not it's you know we'll find out in the
future so let's go back to what do we
want from a generative model we want a
good fit to the training data really the
underlying distribution not just
memorizing the data but some
understanding the distribution the data
is coming from for a new X the ability
to evaluate the probability of that X is
it a likely or unlikely X under the
distribution ability to sample from the
learn distribution and generate new
samples that
way and a latent representation or
embedding space that's meaningful can be
nice to have because then maybe you can
train something on top of that or you
can do interpolations between different
items that are
meaningful recall lecture two
autoaggressive models um they actually
check many boxes um except the sampling
is serial one pixel at a time one token
at a time so it's slow to generate
things there's no parallelization during
generation aive models lack a latent
representation or embedding space yes
you can find tune them but there's still
not that natural kind of setup that you
have in some other models like the one
we'll cover today and in some future
lectures some other
models and at least in terms of what
experimentally has been successful
autois of models have been really about
discrete data and it might have
something to do with the serial aspect
I'm not saying it's guaranteed to be the
case because it's serial if you go
continuous it's often hard to stay on
distribution and then once you sample
one thing the next thing you go further
and further off distribution and all
bets are off whereas with discrete
you're almost naturally rounded back
onto distribution in some sense and so
maybe with this serial generation models
discreete can just naturally uh work
better but again I mean these are not
proven things these are just
considerations flow models so I should
check all the boxes in some sense but so
far the performance is not as good as
for the other model so you get all your
boxes checked but not with the same
level of performance as some of the
other models
have let's
see so our goal will be to fit a density
model P Theta of X with now a continuous
X in some n dimensional
space um what we want the things are
listed on the previous slide good fit to
the trending data ideally the online
distribution ability to evaluate P Theta
so do inference ability to sample and
hopefully a good um embedding
space we'll go in uh really three steps
here and then have a little extra uh bit
on dequantization um so we'll start with
1D flows later foundations for
everything we'll do next we'll do 2D as
the kind of simplest generalization of
that and then we'll see the general
version which will directly build and
everything we'll have covered by
then the last part decline ization what
does that refer to um as I said flow
models are for continuous
valued variables and distributions over
I guess real numbers or um Vector valued
um real real
numbers um what if your data is
discret the notion of dequantization is
the idea that you turn your discrete
data into continuous data so that your
data becomes a fit for training a
continuous density model on the data
might seem a bit weird if the data is
actually discret why would you make a
continuous well to make it fit with
these kinds of models kind of have to do
it and we'll see
why okay so we'll work with probability
densities this time rather than discrete
um
distributions so quick reminder what
does it mean to be a probability density
here's one example P of X um at any
given
um point along the x-axis
you can read off a value for p of X but
that P of X for example this p p of X
over here which is about four doesn't
mean that the probability of the
corresponding
thing down here is four that's not the
meaning with a density with a density
the meaning is that if you take any
finite interval and you take the
integral over that interval you get the
probability of your sample Landing
inside that interval so the meaning is
the probability of X Landing interval AB
is the integral over that interval of P
of X so for example naturally at the
peak a lot of density is located but
really what it means is that if I take a
interval maybe this interval here call
this a call this B then the
integral is the area under the curve in
that interval and that is the
probability associated with Landing in
that
section the probability of any specific
number is actually zero with these
continuous value distributions um
because then your interval is zero
length and if it's zero length then the
integral is
zero okay um how to fit a density model
let's say we have some continuous data
and we now want to fit a maximum
likelihood model as we've seen in last
lecture it's a pretty natural way to fit
if you can formulate your fitting
problem as a maximum some likelihood
problem you get a lot of good properties
so we take a parameterized density model
P Theta and then maximize the log
likelihood of the training data under uh
that model and equivalently since most
optimizers these days are set up to be
minimizers or out the maximizers you
formulate the negative log likelihood as
your training objective and then run
your Optimizer to hopefully find a good
minimum or the minimum if there's a
global
minimum okay so that's very similar to
what we saw last
time
um by the way I just want to flag this
it is possible when you have continuous
data to discretize it and then fit a
discrete model it is an option in some
sense it's what pictures do the real
world is well I guess it's photons so
it's hard to know I mean but how much
energy the photons have is it quantized
it's pretty complicated but it's closer
to continuous than discreet we turn it
into pixels which is discreet same with
speech we turn to discreet values before
we did anything with it in last lecture
it is a possibility it can make sense at
times but not what we're covering
today so we're going to fit a density
model to this
data what's an example of a density
Model A mixture of gaussians or you know
there could be two gaans in this case
there could be more than two how do you
represent that the probability density
again this is a density um is the
weighted sum of the densities associated
with each of the gaussians so in the
simplest case if you have two gaussians
maybe each has a weight of a half you do
one half weight on first one one and
half on the second one and then these
two gaans just get sum together with
half weight each and together form the
probability
density well generally if you had a
mixture of gaussians the parameters you
would try to learn are the mixture
weights that have to sum to one and then
the mean of each GA and the let's say
standard deviation or variance of each
gaan now even though that might sound
good and maybe for some scenarios you
want to fit a mixture of gions we know
that ultimately we're interested in
fitting High dimensional distribution so
we want to think a little bit ahead even
though right now we're thinking about 1D
data want to do with a way that we think
ahead to higher dimensional
data and so what happens let's say when
you're trying to fit a mixture of
gaussians to images you have a bunch of
images which are high dimensional
vectors right you're going to fit a
mixture of gaussians to them and then
you sample from that mixture of gaussin
if this image was in the training data
you might end up with something like
this because effectively you're saying
that near maybe that's one of the means
near the mean of your fit
a gausian
perturbation is acceptable and still
makes for a good image but that's
actually not true once you perturb every
pixel with gaussian noise you get
actually a very unlikely picture and so
this notion that fitting a bunch of
gaussians would lead to a good result in
high dimensional space would clearly be
flawed for images because nearby there's
actually no not that many good images so
somehow that notion of like nearby is
not correct the original pixel
space now I'm saying not correct in the
original pixel space you can imagine
what we're going to do next um what
we're going to do is we're going to
transform from the original space into
another space so flows are when I say a
flow or flow model it refers to the
transformation from X into Z you have
some input
X bun of computation happens gets turned
into Z yes
question so this time
what you're saying
the are that a
gan sort of like put heavy density on a
value and then every value around that
is sort of like has similar density and
then it sort of Curves off are you
saying that that
representation isn't really a
representation of um
the distribution that will represent
like Structure images because something
nearby might not make so much sense you
might not be able to see what it look
like clearly but it would be um like
near the value of of right yeah I like
the way you phrase it and to to play it
back through through the recording also
um
essentially the problem if we use a
mixture of gaussians to model image data
and pixel space is is that if we want to
assign higher probability to any of our
training images we're automatically also
assigning higher probability to very
nearby images as measured in pixel space
and I show you an example of what a
nearby pixel a nearby image in pixel
space looks like and it's not a
desirable image to generate it's not a
natural image that would be in our
natural image distribution and so it
forces that density to be also on that
image which we don't want
another question
so as a follow to this does that mean
that
the get out of the model is fixed by the
amount of that we
have if you did a mixture model says say
mixture of gals model on
images if you wanted to get your
original images to at least to be
regenerated reliably you probably need a
mixture component for each of the
original images but you'll still have
that leaking into what's nearby if you
have less mixture components you'll have
you know weird interpolations in pixel
space happening between these existing
images that are not natural images at
all but will'll still have a high
probability density associated with them
and so clearly directly fitting a
continuous distribution that is a
mixture of Gins in that original pixel
space would lead to a result that is not
not a great result that we're looking
for yeah um is it because we that it's
hard to learn these parameters or
because it's not possible to that's a
good question is it a learnability
question or is it a just a
representation would be flawed if you
just use a mixture of Gans directly in
pixel space the representation is just
flawed even the
best choice of parameters you found the
local no the global optimal of parameter
settings you would still end up with
something that has the same issue
where these two images that are shown on
the slide would have similar probability
density associated with them um you
could say what about in the extreme if I
put super tall Peaks on every training
data point and I'm done with anything
leak it just like zero variance Peaks
well then you got nothing but your
training data covered now you literally
have no generalization at all so either
you literally memorize your training
data or you get this kind of thing where
you put probability on neighboring
things as measured neighboring in pixel
space which would lead to non-natural
images
yes so yeah question good question what
if we tried a different distribution
rather than a gausian and I think that
that kind of really gets to the core of
the leure I love that question
um what what choices do we have right I
mean we have gaussians we can do a
mixture of gaussians um maybe there are
a couple of other parameterized
distributions out there that we can um
somehow you know represent analytically
and then do an optimization over but the
choices are not there's not that many
choices essentially that we have to work
with and
so that's why what we're going to do is
we're going to in some sense admit
defeat that the number of parameterized
distributions that we get to work with
are relatively small and none of them
are a natural fit for natural images or
for other type of data like speech but
maybe after transformation of variables
if we choose the right transformation of
variables they could become a natural
fit and because we'll train them that
we'll train the transformation of
variables such as to try to get a good
fit we're training that transformation
to make those really limited
expressiveness distributions still
succeed at modeling the data in this new
space so that's that's the idea with
flow models um but you're right if we
have had a very rich Suite of
distributions to choose from somehow um
which we don't but if we had maybe we
could directly try to model one of those
but this is one way to get that we're
going to say the way we achieve a wider
range of distributions is by considering
transformations of variables and only
fitting after that and that way we have
much more
flexibility and so the flow is the
transformation of variables so a flow
model will take the original input
process it and generate an embedding Z
which we'll call f of x some function of
X and we're trying to learn that
function because we want to somehow
transform things such that we land in a
space where let's say a gaussian or
maybe another easy to parameterize
distribution would be a good fit to fit
that transform
data in flow models we also require that
that F Theta is invertible so if you go
from X to Z you should be able to go
right back to X that's convenient right
because if you learn an invertible
mapping well if this Z is a comes from a
distribution that's easy like a gaussian
or a uniform or something that you can
just sample from that Gauss or uniform
use the inverse mapping and generate an
X that comes hopefully from the right
distribution that you care about um note
that it's also limiting right and we'll
see that that's if I really skip ahead I
think why flow models maybe haven't the
same level of performance as many of the
other models is the fact that this has
to be invertible and being invertible
constrains you um quite a bit I think if
anything it's surprising how good
they've been despite this constraint so
maybe it could be even better I could be
surprised even more in the future
but that constraint means for example
that Z will have the same dimensionality
as
X because otherwise actually you can't
do the inverse mapping um
also if you don't want it to be
invertible you feel it's too
constraining you want to maybe learn the
inverse mapping and say why not map one
way and then learn in the other
direction sure next lecture Vee lecture
four is essentially the same thing but
we'll learn the
inverse um making things more flexible
your Z can have a higher or a lower
Dimension than x it's all
okay but it is an interesting question
right because if you constructure it
with f theeta invertible a lot of your
problems are automatically solved
sampling becomes just an inversion so
very very simple to get that
done okay so that's the main idea we
transform X into Z we're going to learn
that transformation and then we're going
to fit a distribution to the transform
variables that we have a easy
parameterization for yes thank you so
one thing that I'm just kind of thinking
about is like when we talking about this
mixture of GA being like a ation I
understand like why it would be a flaw
representation intuitively but sometimes
when you're trying to solve a new
problem find a new way of representing
things it's really hard to know in
advance is there like any way of being
able to tell other than just trying
everything just because when your
compute limited for example when we're
like at a university and we're doing
research kind of what is the best way of
kind of building intuition around these
things sometimes things that you would
expect to be well don't turn out very
well yeah it's a really good question
how how do you know whether the
distribution class that you assume might
or might not be a good fit or the neural
network that structure that you're
assume and might or might not be a good
fit I think there's no perfect recipe
for that I think the the kind of best
practice is something along the lines of
you check in the literature for similar
data um what has simly worked well for
other people that can give you some
intuition then when you start running
your own experiments you might first run
an experiment where you only have one
training example and you make sure that
at least the one training example it
knows what to do with it because that
should be easy you should be able to
just overfit that's also a debugging
thing make sure it works from there you
go to a few more training examples you
make sure the fit is there again it's
not the model you want but it checks
that your model class is expressive
enough to at least capture what's in
your trading data then you might
actually see if you can over fit your
entire training set again that shows
that your model has the capacity to do
it that might be good it might be that
it means you're overfitting but then
that's a thing you can resolve after
that you say okay I'm fitting the
training data I'm memorizing a little
too much maybe I need more
regularization other things you know
Dropout all kinds of things that might
help it regularize rather than being
fully overfit but I would go from you
know look at literature try to overfit
to then make sure in the end that it
also generalizes I see yeah and for the
generalization you just basically try
out different regularization techniques
data
augmentation yeah I mean these things T
tend to not be very well prescribed but
exactly you try different levels of
regularization you might try different
learning rates you might try um
different data augmentation techniques
and there are many of them out there um
you might also try a different model
class you might think that maybe a sort
of model class has a better inductive
bias than another model class right for
example a fully connected like
multi-layer perceptron for learning A
visual representation might not be so
ideal might not generalize as well as
let's say a convenant or a Transformer
model so yeah there's there's a lot of I
guess dark art in some sense that that
you need to acquire over time yes is it
safer dangerous to assume that neural
networks are like generally bed
functions from the Dom s to do Z yeah I
think that's a really good question it's
it's really the Crux of of a lot of
what's coming in class but just to
preview most most neural Nets will not
be an invertible transformation so a lot
of what you need to do with flow models
is to constrain your neural network to
make sure it is invertible and not just
invertible but efficiently invertible
because some functions are invertible
would take tremendous amount of compute
to invert and then maybe it's still not
the right um function class to work with
so a lot of the effort goes into
that and in fact I would argue it's not
even perfectly understood like
how exactly does this constrain you um I
will show you a bit later that flow
models are fully General that you can
represent any distribution with a flow
model assuming a large enough flow model
but that's almost like saying you know
any 1D distribution can be represented
with a mixture of gaussians if you have
enough mixture components but that
doesn't mean it's like the right
distribution in terms of inductive buys
and so
forth but in that sense the flow models
are General if you're just like okay I'm
going to just make a very large model at
some point I can definitely fit things
but
yeah
yes so I like this I like this idea what
if we think of the F Theta as something
like doing a fre8 transform I think
that's definitely a viable thing to put
in there um that's a viable change of
bases that has worked well for a lot of
signal processing applications so you
could definitely imagine that in that
space it's easier to fit the
distribution than in the original space
um to some extent for images maybe even
to more extent for audio
um now the Hope might be that you can
learn something even more General but I
think it is a good class of functions to
to consider um one thing that I'll maybe
foreshadow right now is that if if you
have a one step is invertible and the
next step is invertible the composition
is Al also invertible so if your idea is
to insert a forier transform you could
do that followed by all the other things
followed by yet something else and so
forth so all your ideas can stack
serially together which is pretty
interesting and that might also be why
they actually do surprisingly well and
that you can bring a lot of ideas to
play in different layers such that you
still get a decent amount of
expressiveness yes
one last question regarding the flow
model like because you want it to be
fully invertible does that mean you're
limited to which like activation
functions you want to use like for
example a sigmoid is invertible but like
a Ru is not because any of the negative
values all get M to zero so you can't
bring it back so do flow models restrict
you from using certain activation
functions they absolutely do yeah as you
said A Rue model Maps everything
negative to zero so it's not invertible
can't put that in your network um now if
you know everything is always positive
if you have a guarantee in your data
then but then the Rue is just a linear
function and um not sure it matters to
call it a rue then
so so what do we need to do to fit um
this
correctly because the last thing we want
to do is just say let's transform all
our data into zspace put it all onto the
exact same Z
and then we do maximum likelihood on the
on zspace and we get such a great score
because everything's on the same point
and think that we're done because that
that doesn't work it's not invertible
but also we don't want some um close by
version of that to be possible so the
right way to do it is is to study the
change of variables formula so if Z is a
function of
X um then let me draw this out here so
let's say x lives over
here we're in 1D so it's easy to draw Z
lives over there and Z is some function
of X for example
maybe a function like this of X what
that means is that if I have an X for
example this X over here it'll
map to this C over
there okay um now what we want is we
really want to model the original data
which will have a density so maybe X has
a density that you know what let's let's
keep it um let's keep it somewhat simple
let's say x has a density that is
uniform up to here let's say nothing
goes past
here so X has a uniform
density now when I map to
Z I want essentially to be the case that
as I look at an
interval around X this original X here I
look at the probability Mass
here and then I want the density of Z to
be such
that that same mass gets mapped over to
the nearby interval in zspace so I take
the um left let me add some color here I
take this Point here which it's
mapped over here I take the other end of
the
interval which gets
mapped over here and so I want the
interval between the blue and the green
to capture the same amount of integral
for Z and for x and so if
we maybe look at this and we say Okay
this may be a slope of 1/2 the slope of2
um and then later the slope will be much
steeper what happens is that this
interval
here because the slope is pretty shallow
actually gets mapped to a smaller
interval in Z space and so what it means
if that for this small if this Mass only
need to be transported into the smaller
interval in Z
space we will get actually a
taller density
for the Z space there to make sure that
all the probability mass is space to get
into because we let's say divide it in
half the length of the interval so it
needs to be twice as tall to fit the
same probability
Mass that's kind of finite probability
point of view what needs to happen um
then here where the slope is much
steeper we look at a small interval
here this small interval
well that should be mapped to a wider
interval and so this probability masse
on the X side is essentially the same
but on Z it's much wider and so the
density here for Z will be more
something like this right and now we see
there's a curve with a kink in it so
essentially what'll what'll happen is
everything up to that point will be
behaving the same for Z so every Z will
have something that looks like this and
then drops
down here to this kind of density then
it stops over
here so this here is the Z density we
end up with for this particular
transformation
um making that more precise at the kind
of tiny interval level the DXs and the
dzs what we're saying is that the
density around the point x * DX needs to
be the density around Z *
DZ but it needs to be the DC that
corresponds to the DX it needs to be
just like when we transfer that interval
from the horizontal axis to the vertical
axis it changed size this DX and DZ they
need to correspond they're not the same
size you need to transform X to Z space
to see what that size is and you might
wonder how much does that size change
that's this thing over here this is d Z
over
DX it's measuring how much does it
change when I go from X to Z space and
what it really is just a derivative of
the function so to know how much the
density
changes we just need to look at the
derivative of the function and that'll
tell us how much the density changes
because that tells how much the interval
gets scaled up or scaled down locally to
compensate for that the density goes the
other
way
um this I mean I'm obviously not proving
this I'm just trying to give some
intuition for it um this is a well
established result in standard
probability Theory this is what
underlies everything we do with flows
because if we follow this prescribed
formula we know that now if we fit a
density in zspace it will properly M
back map back out to a density in X
space there will be a proper
correspondence between the
two note that um this thing here needs
to be differentiable usually that's not
a problem most functions that we like to
use with NE Nets are differentiable so
it's not a big requirement um also needs
to be invertible otherwise we can't do
this now one of you might maybe say well
is it really necessary to be invertible
to do this can't we extend this right
what if this continued and you know this
function went back down
here you know all the way
here what what would happen if I took a
function like that so now my function
is f Theta goes like this and continues
and there is some going back down so not
invertible I can still transport a
probability Mass I can still say okay
for every X that's over here I can see
where it lands and push probability Mass
there and so what I end up with is
effectively a sum for every Z I need to
look at all the X's that could land in
in that neighborhood and Su together
terms that look like this that's kind of
annoying to do probably um much less
convenient to work
with then on the way back you got to
decide what to do where does it go back
to which of the X's does it go back to
sometimes an X here sometimes an X there
you're going to have a very poorly
conditioned situation because then the Z
I mean in this case the Z that's over
here will sometimes M back to an X here
and sometimes M back to an X there that
is very poor conditioning in most
scenarios where your embedding space
then explodes into completely different
things somehow um just randomly coin
toss so even though maybe there is a way
you can make it work with not invertible
mathematically theoretically speaking
set something up in practice it's
probably never going to work well um and
even be very hard to implement anything
for it so in flow models it's assumed
invertible and
differentiable so so what does the
training look like if we have more than
one data point we just repeat this
objective so maximum likelihood log
probabilities under the density for X
but we don't directly parameterize the
density for X this is kind of just this
is just conceptual P Theta of X it's a
conceptual thing there is no such thing
that we have where like oh what is it no
really what we do is we transform X into
zspace model the density there and have
this compensation term because of the
slope in the curve compressing or
extending intervals from X to Z you need
to make up for
that okay this can be optimized with
gradient descent stochastic gradient
descent so in some sense you're good to
go if you find a function class that is
invertible
differentiable then you can just run
this and find a good set of parameters
uh Theta now here I've assume that this
pzz is a given often that's done you
might say oh maybe it's just a unit
gussan for 1D or it's uniform
distribution uniform you need to make
sure you map on to zero1 of course with
your transformation um or maybe it's
another simple distribution in principle
you can also parametrize this one and
learn some additional parameters um it's
kind of exchangeable to having more
layers in the network or then uh
parameterize the distribution at the end
it's uh it's the same um in this case I
just set it up at has um a fixed known
distribution that you need to map
into okay now and a lot of your
questions anticipated this love those
questions um we know what a flow model
is like the summary at the top here in
some sense tells us everything we need
to know but we need to make some choices
we need to choose F Theta and we need to
choose the embedding space density pz
what can we choose for f Theta in
1D an invertible function is actually
not that many choices in some sense
invertible means you either
monotonically keep going up or
monotonically keep going down if you
ever turn around in Direction you become
not invertible okay so ax plus b for
positive a where A and B are your
parameters polinomial with positive
coefficients only and only oddd uh
powers
X Theta * X where Theta is a parameter
sigmoid ax +
B cumul any cumulative density function
by the way sigmoid is one example
anything that goes from 0 to one as a
cumulative density function is monotonic
is
invertible um probably your pz should be
a uniform over 01 then because you're
not going to go outside of 01 um but
that's that's a reasonable choice you
can have pretty complicated cdfs you can
compose flow so you can chain these
together to get again a flow now if
you're wored in your optimization setup
about this notion oh my parameter has to
be positive you can play little tricks
like you can say instead of having a
parameter a that needs to be bigger than
zero have a
parameter a bar of which you take the
exponent exponentiated version of a bar
and now you're always positive um so
there is ways to do that without having
to introduce hard constraints on your
optimization when you look at this list
you're probably a little bit
disappointed right because there's
nothing in there that says um you know
attention Network or anything like that
it's at least for 1 D in higher D we
have a bit more optionality but in 1D
options are limited now at the same time
1D distributions what what can they
really be there's not so much they can
be if you the choice of all cumulative
density functions you kind of have it
all covered so maybe it's okay
if your Z your pz here is normal 01 it's
called a normalizing flow a lot of
people talk about normalizing flows
that's what it means could be a mixture
of
Gauss um that's a reasonable choice you
could learn the parameters of that
mixture of G so you could set them ahead
of time it could be a uniform but then
you better make sure F Theta maps to 01
so if you have a uniform and you Maps
outside of 01 then you'll have a zero
probability you'll take the log of a
zero probability you'll have a negative
infinity or optimization will blow up
yes
I
yeah so first
so here um this this sort of math would
the this isort of say that whatever
function we learn with with whatever
parameters that's called form are input
into some sort of like
Le this is saying that
um we would choose an Easy distribution
for example like a g and then the output
of the model that we learn theam
of um I I'll give some examples soon so
why don't we hold off on that question
for
now do you have another question or was
it very related then maybe also hold off
yeah I um I guess the other question
was so I see that the here are of
like model
equ as far and I know you talked about
to constru to Inver um like what is the
parameters like how how
one
people model okay yeah let me let me let
me defer that question to later okay but
it's the right question it's the right
anticipation of what we need to think
about but I have a bunch of slides on
that and so I'll wait till those pop
up let's look at some examples so we
have a density
um here that we just visualize in
principle we would just have data right
some samples but I'm visualizing here
the density that these samples are
coming from we have an initialization of
our flow transformation which results in
this density over here for
Z so just to be very clear this side is
X this is a flow X to Z and then this is
z um after training because we're
fitting on to a gaussian uh unit
normal uh distribution we learn a f
Theta of flow that indeed transform this
original density which has two peaks
into a gaussian no approximately um one
one Peak U maybe just need a little bit
more training to to smooth that out um
so that's one example of what could
happen or what you could
do here's another one we go to uniform
so it's a essentially um the same
distribution but now is shown in a
sampling way again left is X middle is
the flow on the right is the resulting
distribution for Z initially it's
obviously a very simple transformation
um it is not anywhere close to uniform
um it still has those two peaks then
when it's the learning is done um it
transforms this two peak distribution
that could go anywhere on the real line
into a 01 on uniform distribution or
close to
it here's another example again on the
left it's X in the middle is the flow on
the right it's um the transformation Z
samples the resulting
Transformations initially again the flow
here is just a simple um sigmoid we map
on to a beta 55 which is a more it's a
peak distribution but still over the 01
interval um think of it as like a
gaussian with finite support is maybe
you know cly speaking what a beta 55 is
um initially you still see the two peaks
come through but then it learns a flow
that models it into the Beta 55
distribution okay so 1D flow models
quick summary um we start from some X
space it's not a good space to directly
put simple distributions in that's why
we transform it into a new space and we
hope that we can force that
transformation to be good enough that we
can use a simpler uh pz in this new
space that is easy to work with that is
also hopefully easy to sample from
because when we sample from pz we invert
F Theta we get X back out it's easy to
evaluate the probability of a new uh
data point you get so sometimes we we've
solved everything we've already
anticipated a pain in terms of
expressiveness but all the boxes are
checked in terms of what we expect from
a generative
model all right
now let's look at a special case which
comes up quite a bit let's assume z f
Theta of X is a cumulative density
function and pz is going to be uniform
okay what does it mean to be a
cumulative density function cumulative
density function means that essentially
when you have a regular density let's
say um P I'll just well I might use x PX
of x uh the
density um assigns this probability to
each interval so you might have a
density
that might look who knows maybe like a
gaussian then the cumulative density
function or
CDF so she integrates all probability
encountered so far so it goes up goes up
steeper steeper it is the steepest at
the peak here at that top and then it
starts the slope
attenuates and then slope becomes zero
because it becomes zero here and this
cumulative density will go from zero to
one because it's integrating all
probability Mass from negative Infinity
to where you are right now and that
total should be one okay the PDF and the
purple one lives on a different scale I
guess otherwise it's not going to
integrate to one probably so that's a
CDF the interesting thing about a
CDF is that when you use a CDF you map
on to 01 so you can use a uniform
distribution as the Z distribution which
is a convenient one to work with because
the term that involves Z doesn't even do
anything it uh there's nothing to
optimize there it just always a constant
so you just have the other term to deal
with something that's kind of intriguing
if you look at let me see if I on the
next slide or all right have an example
here so more complicated example if you
look at this double bump you get this
cumulative density that kind of ramps up
fast at the first Peak then slows down
ramps up even faster again at the next
Peak and then gets to
one you can sample um via the inverse so
if you
sample in 01 uniformly and then map it
out through the inverse of that
cumulative density you get a sample out
so really what I've told you here is
that a cumulative density function is a
flow that flows your original
distribution for X right onto uniform so
in some you say what you know what would
I want to find that might be a pretty
good one to find if I'm using pz uniform
then essentially I'm looking to find
this CDF in my sequence of function
approximations um so you can think of
that special case where the end is
uniform as everything in between
effectively modeling the CDF in some way
because that's when you're get the best
fit to your data and that's what you'll
end up with if the optimization works
out well and it's easy to sample from um
just as we cribe
now one thing that's
intriguing about this is if you look at
the equation
here right we're turning a flow model
and let's say
the final thing is uniform so this is
uniform uniform 01 so that's a constant
doesn't do anything to the optimization
all you're left with is this part over
here
and now if f theeta is a cumulative
density function so we have D the
CDF respect to x
x this is actually equal to P Theta of X
So In This Very Special case there's
just a very close correspondence to
directly modeling your P Theta of X so
if all you do is you put in one
cumulative density function that's all
you do and map on to 01 it's equivalent
to directly modeling the corresponding
probability density which you kind of
want it to be but I just want to point
that out so the simplest flow where you
say oh I use a CDF of a gaussian to flow
onto uniform is the same thing as just
fitting a maximum likel Gauss to the
data if you say I'm going to flow with a
CDF that is a mixture of gaussians
that's the same thing as fitting a
mixture of gaussian to the data now of
course the beauty of NE Nets is that you
want much more complicated stacking of
expressive
before you get to the other side but in
the very simple scenarios it degenerates
to kind of what you'd for but also means
that it is not doing much in those
cases yeah so this is the the slides
version types version of what we just uh
looked
at you might wonder how General R flows
can every smooth distribution be
represented by a normalizing flow we'll
just think about one for now who think
every distribution can be represented by
a
flow some of you okay some of you raised
your hands here you're in front you
raised your hand why do you think it's
the
case W I think if it's not people would
lose hope on this I like it so it's a
strong prior on why people even spend
time on flows if it's not capable of
doing this why why would we even study
it um that that's a pretty good prior um
I fully agree with that uh sentiment um
and we're going to give a slightly more
first principles answer um in in what
we're going to derive
here I just showed you that to go from X
to
uniform just requires the CDF of X so
assuming I make my flow expressive
enough to be able to represent any CDF
let's say a mixture of sufficiently many
gaussians or a
um let's say um a mixure of Logistics um
CDF with enough components I can flow X
from X to
uniform if on the output I want the Z of
any distribution I can find a flow from
Z to uniform the same way so I can get X
to uniform I can get Z to uniform now I
just invert this guy and take the
inverse of that guy put it over here and
I end up with a flow that goes from any
distribution over X to any distribution
over Z so in that sense it's very
general
um that doesn't mean it has the right
inductive bias always and trains the
fastest and so forth but it shows that
it is
possible okay um quick recap for of flow
models in
1D flow is a differentiable invertible
mapping from X which is the data to Z
which is your noise space you train it
so that it turns a data distribution
into a base distribution pz the common
choices are uniform or standard normal
for pz that
is this is the objective you
optimize and at the bottom here's an
example your F goes from X to Z and F
inverse goes back um this here was flown
uh the flow was done to a gaussian uh
use the sample from a gausian and then
invert to get a sample from the original
distribution over X
the reason I like to continue putting
this up front here even though you don't
really directly use it is to clarify
that this is actually what we're doing
we are correctly modeling a density over
X by following this prescribed formula
uh that you need to use when you do a
change of variables and model densities
yes is there any point in choosing
anything other than a uniform
distribution uniform is very popular you
just need to make sure you end up
between zero and one otherwise you have
trouble but you can do that just in the
last layer if you want one reason you
might not want it is because maybe as
you squash things between zero and one
you your gradients kind of flatten out
and so maybe it's it's harder to get
signal if you're not exactly initialized
in the right space and so maybe flowing
onto a
normal has less of those issues compared
to flowing onto a uniform 01 um but but
if you have good good ways to resolve
that and get your gradients to come
through just fine and the signal flows
you know pre optimization then in some
sense it's fully General because you say
if I map on to a normal I can just
follow it by a normal CDF and that'll
turn it into 01 so if I just hard code
that last layer I'm effectively you know
flowing onto a uniform and as long as
the last layer has the you know that
capacity then it's it's kind of the same
it's just adding one layer to switch
between uniform and and
normal
okay we looked at this look at
this oh I think the PDF retained some
slides that I wanted to skip so I
skipped over
them let's look at 2D flows now which
will start giving us some intuition
about what we can do do in higher
Dimensions let's start with
autoagressive flow it's a very specific
choice but given we already covered
autoaggressive models it could be pretty
natural to think about autoaggressive
flows so in autoaggressive
flow we go X1 to Z1 which is what we
just did already nothing new there but
then X2 gets mapped to Z2 but you get to
use X1 and X2
so you're really turning X1 and X2 into
a Z2 together
um so you can only generate well you can
actually do this in parallel the
training can be done in parallel but
then when you go in the other direction
you sample you'll need to wait the first
one you invert just the same way it's a
1D flow you just invert it the way we've
been doing it but then the second one
here um when you
inverted you need
to this one has a let's see you have Z2
that is sampled you need to wait for X1
to have been generated before you're
able to invert so it's a kind of an
interesting situation just like in
autoaggressive models in last lecture
when you're sampling it's very slow it's
one at a time but when you're when
you're training it all goes through in
parallel you can train very
fast you might say what's really
different from autoagressive models that
we saw last lecture is in some sense the
way we model the distribution it's still
essentially the chain rule that we're
applying it's now the way we model the
chain rule is by instead of directly
putting down a p a distribution for the
next variable we say we're going to
model as a flow into a new variable
which we then have a parameterized
distribution for um but lot of strong
similarities let me pause here because
this is probably the you know most
important base case for everything that
comes in higher Dimensions yes so when
we're getting X2 why
is inverse that
X12 instead
of1 great question why why not use Z1
here instead of X1
right that's called a inverse
autoaggressive flow so that exists too
we'll talk about it they're both
reasonable models and we'll we'll talk
about both um I agree both are
reasonable
choices
and the beauty of taking in Z1 there you
don't have to wait at sampling time it
does turn out that then at training time
and we'll see that soon enough you'll
get kind of almost the counterpart of an
RNN where the z's are the hidden State
you need to wait for the previous Z to
be generated to be able to generate the
next one so training will be seral like
an RNN in the inverse flows inverse
autoaggressive flows but then sampling
will be
fast yeah
mhm whichever is more important you care
more about fast training or more or more
about uh fast uh sampling will'll
determine which one of the two you want
to use and there are some ways to get
the best of both uh which we'll also
talk
about oh something I want to really
highlight here is that the dependence on
X1 in F Theta 2 can be arbitrarily
complex
so when when F Theta 2 is computed here
it takes in an X1 and
X2 it turns X2 into Z2 and that needs to
be invertible you're constrainted to
make that invertible but X1 is a given
it's like a known when you're doing that
and the way you use X1 doesn't matter as
long as you know no matter what choice
of X1 makes this thing whole thing still
invertible so you need to take care of
that but there needs to be nothing
particularly constraining about how you
process X1 there so let me show you an
example
um let's say I have X1 over here it goes
into a mixture of gausian cumulative
density function transformation two
components in this case the means and
variances are the Theta 1 parameters
turns it into
Z1 Next Step um I'm going to transform
X2 into Z2 also with a mixture of Gan
cumulative density
function what I can do is this
parameters mu and sigma Can Depend using
any arbitrary neural net structure here
on X1
so the in some the interaction you
create between X1 and X2 can be pretty
rich to achieve Z2 in the sense that
your X1 can be processed by any neural
network in this
Branch not in the top in the top X1 is
just pass through a cumulative density
function to map it under the
corresponding Z so the the top path here
for X1 is very simple just like
cumulative density see where you map but
the bottom path for X1 can be anything
models with ATT tension convolutions
anything you want can all go in there so
that's where more expressiveness is
starting to come in in One D we don't
have that because in 1D just if the one
variable needs to be invertible can I
have no no wiggle room in 1D to go
anywhere in 2D we start having more
wiggle room another thing that's
interesting to think about is that a
composition of flows is still a flow so
if you were like man I really want to
nonlinearly process X2 also at some
point you can just stack another one
behind it here where you swap the rolls
of X1 and X2 and it's still a flow
because it's just two flows composed
together in the autog of models we
looked at before you had to follow the
strict ordering you couldn't like let
things arbitrary ways depend on each
other but here because we enforce the
invertibility we're able to put FL flow
after flow after flow so you can
actually start getting pretty complex
once you have just two Dimensions what
you're able to express you can repeat
this multiple times after each other and
so you can actually get a lot of more
complex calculation happening on these
of course it would be happening on Z2
here and Z1 so what I'm saying is if
there were another flow stacked there I
could um first do Z2 with a simple
cumulative density function flow and
then I could for Z1 condition in a
complex way on Z2 to get its
transformation
out
question
you a little deer into
why the
transation yeah absolutely so just to be
clear the let me let me erase what um I
drew on the slide for a moment
let's
see so X1 is over
here when it goes through the CDF to get
onto Z1 that's a very simple thing
that's essentially I have X1 living here
I have Z1 living here I have a mixture
of Gan CDF which we know what it roughly
looks like it bumps up and it bumps up
again right go from 0 to one so that top
mapping where where it jumps up that's
essentially
mu1 and mu2 and then how wide that bump
is corresponds to Sigma 1 and sigma 2
that's parameterized up there right and
this x mapping is very simple you just
choose whatever your X is you have to go
right through it that's your only choice
you can just change that CDF a little
bit now at the bottom here here we're
essentially doing the same
thing for
X2 now when we're doing this for X2 we
also have a essentially a
mu1 I actually called it mu2 one on the
slide because because could be different
than the other one and a
mu
22 and we can choose where they land and
what I'm saying is that I can I don't
need to just independent of X1 choose
where they are I can let my choice of
M's depend on X1 I can take a neural
network that processes X1 and decides
what these M's are and so what that
means is that for example if I have a
distribution that
maybe I don't know looks like a lot of
mass here and a lot of mass here and
this is
X1 and this is X2 what I can model then
is this notion that if X1 landed
somewhere here which means that most
likely X2 should be somewhere here I can
model that because I can effectively say
if X1 Lies over there my me has to be
roughly there even with a single me I
could actually model this if my n
network is complex enough I can have the
me take on this value here for X that
x1's that are here and I can take the M
on this value for X's that are x1's that
are out here and so this the reason it
stays invertible is because to go back
from Z2 to X2 it doesn't matter where I
dropped those
M's um wherever they landed I know where
they landed because I know the
calculation from X1 to those M so I know
the CDF I can just look up in the CDF to
go back from Z2 to
X2 yeah I guess in your one case there
were some dations s of motivating like
the requirement of being Inver so I'm
guess I guess question I guess so I'm
guessing that none of this like you know
I can take some from
auror my I guess that does not mess up
any of
whatever
Inver
function depend on
is
in
inun yeah so the
inverse of this one here F Theta 2 when
I want to invert it I will need to know
X1 cuz I used X1 to generate this CDF
here without access to X1 I don't have
access to that CDF so I cannot invert so
I need access to X1 or because we know
Z1 and X1 can be mapped between each
other access to Z1 either way I need
access to that information be able to
produce the correct Muse that give me
this CDF but that's all I need to remain
invertible the the complexity of how
these mes depend on X1 does not affect
the invertibility I just need to know
that for given X1 there will be some 's
and then I can use them to go back and
forth between X2 and
Z2 and we'll look at the math I think on
the next slide here which what you were
asking about this is what it looks like
so you have
a well you have two terms now because
there's two variables there's going to
be Z1 Z2 there's a change of variable um
transformation component the log of the
derivative of uh the function at that
point
and at the top here I wrote it with Z's
and at the bottom here I wrote it with f
Theta 1 and F Theta 2 um but that's
essentially the same thing um just a
different notation um the F Theta makes
it more explicit that you're learning a
function from X that becomes um the Z
and then the if you write it like at the
top it's more just saying oh it's you
know it's just wherever um X lands on
zspace the these are this the bottom is
what you would normally use naturally
because that has all the information you
need and so now you have a term like
before and an additional term at the
bottom that is extremely extremely
similar um and that's it if you stack
multiple sequences of these together you
effectively get multiple of these terms
of these transformation terms because
those are the transformation modeling
ones and then the one in the front here
is just the last one that's the density
of the Z at the very end but if you had
more on one layer you get many of these
uh summ
together so let's look at some examples
um this is our data distribution okay
the colors are different just to give
some sense of where the data maps to
right it's one distribution but it's
natural to think of it as two classes
there's two half Moons but the model
does not have access to some
classification label or anything is just
a visualization to have some samples be
yellow some samples be
purple we took a base distribution which
is uniform so we're going to map onto
uniform we use a CDF that's a mixture of
five gaussians to go from X1 to Z1 so
just one layer we're do not not any
stacking or anything just X1 to Z1
mixture five gussi CDF then X2 is also
mixture five GA going to Z2 um but
conditioned so the parameters are
conditioned on
X1 before
training this is what we end up with
latent space here means Z space so
Z1
Z2 that's not going to score very well
because the uniform distribution puts
equal Mass everywhere but we're not
using that mass very well with this
mapping a lot of the mass is getting
lost um then as we train we see that
these samples spread out spread out and
we end up with this thing over
here and this thing here next to it is
the um the density in X space so you can
see it actually modeled the density in X
space quite well with
this so in some sense this is I think
very surprising and intriguing because
this was just a one thing it was just
like one layer we didn't even stack any
layers and we modeled the two moons
problem which is kind of a complicated
configuration and we turn into a uniform
pretty
cleanly if I can give a little bit of
color and subjective opinion on it when
I look at this I'm both excited and I'm
disappointed and I'll say why I'm also
disappointed the reason I'm disappointed
is
because some of the yellow points land
extremely close to some of the purple
points right which means that there's an
extreme sensitivity when I sample in the
uniform space and a sample close to that
boundary where I end up could widly vary
based on just a small perturbation where
I sampled which is usually for an
embedding space not the right thing
usually for an embedding space you want
things that are nearby that actually
represent similar things in the original
space but here you get have points that
are very nearby and one of them is in
one Moon the other one's in the other
Moon and there's like a gap in between
there's literally no data in between
it's an empty space yet they are so
close together now you might say heyy
you just took the wrong thing why do you
take uniform these are clearly two two
clusters you should have done you know a
mixture of two Gauss as the base
distribution and then you would have had
a much cleaner solution I agree with
that that is definitely what would um
would have cleaned it up but then you
kind of pose with the challenge like how
many Gan compones you need and so forth
you start getting a lot of questions in
terms of um hyper parameters you need to
choose to get this right not for the two
moons it's obvious that the base
distribution two you know mixture of two
gs is a great base distri distribution
rather than uniform but in general you
don't have in high Dimensions the
visibility in your data set and so you
can end up with things like this because
it's so it just gets it done we thought
it's not expressive actually it's quite
expressive it just gets it done it
optimizes the objective so well that I
think we end up with something that
actually isn't that great in terms of
embedding space um so we somehow are
still faced with the question of
designing an embedding space for Z that
is a natural one for our our data so we
land in a good spot which is kind of
unfortunate we would still have to do
that effort if you do that effort then
maybe things work out great but You'
hopes for models maybe that don't
require you to design your embedding
space so carefully and what do you even
have available in your embedding space
mixture of gaussians and uniform couple
of other things you don't have that many
options so it's a bit it's a bit tricky
I would
say um here's another one here is um a
flow um that goes from this face density
which has three clusters to uniform
again it Nails it it knows how to model
density so if all you care about is a
really good density model you might
actually be quite happy but if you care
about embeddings you might not be as
happy in this case let me postpone
questions for just a little bit but I
saw your hand or actually we are at the
last slide for 2D yeah let's do the
question
now so I understand what you mean about
how it's not like that confident there
is a lot of ambiguity so if you think
about Confidence from like 0 to one
there's a lot of 0.5 going on here
because it's just so close to like this
boundary between these two different
classes but can you really how do you
know this is fully attributable to the
to the representation you chose right
the five Gans how do you not know it's
just that it wasn't trained in the most
optimal way how can you pinpoint it to
the
representation understand the you that
can create a lot of problems a lot of
things close to each other but like how
do you know it's the creating this issue
well for one I'll say this was very
subjective commentary so take it with a
grain of salt about why I don't like
them Landing close together but the
reason with regards to your specific
question you know why I
think the issue here is with the choice
of the pz is because if you choose pz to
be
uniform yeah your distribution clearly
has two
clusters if you're N Net your flow is
expressive enough it's going to make it
uniform because that is going to score
the highest so you're optimizing a log
black objective that will score the
highest if you turn it into a uniform so
if you're expressive enough you'll turn
it into uniform now I could argue maybe
the flow shouldn't be so expressive I
make it less expressive not going to be
able to turn it into uniform and I can
fix it that way that might be possible
um you could say the uniform is a bad
choice I need something else there but
the choices are kind of like not that
many and so it kind of goes counter to a
lot of the most successful models these
days where you say the larger you make
your model the more expressive you make
it the better it's going to do and here
we're almost saying like oh well we
should be careful about expressing this
because then it'll get these embeddings
that are maybe not the ones we want and
I think that's kind of counter to The
Narrative of we can just scale up and
get better
results now maybe a couple years now we
see here again and we're I'm telling a
story I'm like hey you know two years
ago I said flows weren't seemly going
anywhere but now look you know
completely changed they're the model
everybody uses it's possible I think
it's good to understand at least the
limitations that we encounter right now
because if they are going to be the
thing we'll probably have to think hard
about how to work around these kinds of
things that are not intuitively
satisfactory let's say yes think what
actually creates like the structure of
theing space is specific combination of
the flow
and density or is it one the other and
like if you wanted to include some in
this like yeah would you focus on youred
density
orow yeah um how do we introduce more
inductive bias to get better embeddings
effectively right I think one thing is
indeed you change your um end
distribution away from uniform probably
to have something that's more multimodal
if you think your data is multimodal
because that way you you don't force
things close together that don't belong
close together um the other thing you
you do I think and we'll see this in
higher Dimensions
um you saw how we can essentially take
X1 and have it participate in the
computation of the CDF that we use for
X2 now you know higher dimensional space
you have choices there in the
architecture should the top left pixel
contribute to the bottom right pixel CDF
or not really or if it should contribute
should it be channeled through maybe
something that combines information for
many pixels to then finally have
something that doesn't make it too much
determinate it still can learn that it
depends more on other pixels maybe so I
think the the connectivity pattern in
here is where you can put a lot of
inductive bias and that's also what
people have been doing in higher
dimensions and again I think that the
special thing about flows and why I do
as I said some negatives why I think
they do give surprisingly good results
is that the connectivity pattern in any
given block is what it is but then in
the next block you can switch it up in
one block you can have the top pixels
influence the bottom pixels and next
block you know the bottom pixels
effectively influence the top ones you
can alternate this whichever way you
want you can go left right top bottom um
you know super resolution in some sense
like you know one pixel spread out pixel
spread out and then fill in details you
can make all these choices in the
different blocks and the composition
will still be a flow and that's where
the choice of these blocks is the
inductive bias you put in but also gives
you a very different kind of
expressiveness than the autog models we
saw in last
lecture in the first half of lecture
today we covered the foundations of flow
models 1D 2D and sometimes the big
questions that main is how to represent
these flows in higher Dimensions what
are some of the inductive biases people
have introduced
successfully so
um we're going to model High dimensional
data now um in our case because we're
looking at flow models x and z will have
the same dimensionality I say high
dimensional same dimensionality on both
sides otherwise we can't invert between
the
two okay um autoagressive flows and
inverse autoagressive flows will cover
first
um they will
be you know one variable after the other
that's kind of the definition of
autoaggressive but there are others that
will'll cover after that don't treat
things that
way so autoaggressive flows um it's a
bit like sampling from a Bas net it's a
you know you have a the chain rule you
go X1 then X2 then X3 the same thing
happens in auto agressive flow you get
X1 from Z1 during the inversion X2 from
Z2 and X1 we saw that example in 2D you
can just generalize this to 3D where now
this also depends on x2 um so this is
the
setup
um how to fit
them this is our objective that's been
all along right we have put logs in
front of it we're going to log log of
the first term which is the pz and then
the log of the absolute value of
determinant for the second one
um
this here is the general version if you
have a higher dimensional mapping since
everything in autoaggressive is still
ond mapping for each variable that's
being generated it's really just a sum
of terms um that are all
one-dimensional so Z's get generated
this way way a generalization of what we
saw for 2D and this is how we go
back I like to kind of draw the picture
that it corresponds to um it's similar
to pictures we saw last week um X1
through F Theta becomes
Z1 then X1 and X2 through in principle
on F Theta 2 we can make it all one big
block called all F Theta BEC Z2 we know
that this Arrow here can be very complex
typically this one here tends to be
pretty simple because it needs to be
invertible so if I use different colors
for invertible versus not invertible
this is an invertible process
this is an invertible process and this
is an invertible process but
then purple one this one here or this
one here or this one here here those are
essentially additional ways to
parameterize the F Theta as a way to
think of it and these purple arrows
don't have to be invertible at all you
don't need to go in reverse on those so
much more complex things can happen on
that
front imerse autog of flows I had a
question about that earlier
um if
X1
um One Way think is that you just make
everything that used to be F Theta F
Theta inverse and where everything was F
Theta inverse you make it f Theta but we
end up with this at sampling time X1
becomes a function of Z1 X2 of Z2 Z1 and
X3 Z1 Z2 Z3 so I think it's a little
easier to look at the picture seeing the
next two each
other and and our original Auto flow on
the left
we have these arrows that do the more
complex
conditioning they are replaced by the
red arrows on the right so that's the
difference instead of feeding feeding in
X1 you feed in Z1 instead of feeding in
X2 you feed in Z2 and so forth because
the mapping between X1 Z1 is invertible
information content wise
is the same thing you're fitting in the
same
information but compute wise it's
different because now in an ifaf you can
sample
effectively in everything in parallel
once you have all your z's which you can
sample All In Parallel you can um when
you invert you can go right through to
get all the XIs you don't need to wait
for X1 to generate X2 and so forth so
sampling is fast and here the forward
mapping is fast fast means
parallelizable you know it all in
parallel so put that at the bottom
here so autoaggressive
flow fast evaluation fast training slow
sampling inverse the opposite there are
actually models that manag to get the
best of both worlds you might wonder how
is that
done
essentially
why why is
training why is training slow here
you're essentially turning it into an
RNN right you go from X1 to Z1 which
then has to be processed to get Z2 and
then get to Z3 and so forth um that
makes the process
slow
if you have essentially a corresponding
functions that you set up but you just
change the arrow so they're essentially
the same but you just change the arrows
around if you first train an
autoagressive flow so you train this
which is
fast then you sample from it which
unfortunately going to be a little bit
slow but then you sample from
it so you
train then
sample then you use these samples to
train this one you might say that's
annoying cuz now I'm going to train the
one that's slow to train it turns out if
you look at the
details because these are samples if you
keep the inner activations around you
can actually if you set up the
architecture right and some choices you
have to make in a very precise way you
can actually train the if
fast and so that's a way to train an if
fast is essentially as distilling it
from an autoaggressive flow you can
train it fast and then when you're done
training you can sample fast and so if
you look
at um these models here they exploit
that idea um parallel wave net and ifv
this notion that you essentially distill
the fast trainable autoaggressive flow
into an invertible inverse autoagressive
flow and you do it by using samples
where you keep the activations around
which gives you the missing information
right because the reason the reason
training is slow for the I is because
you don't have
disease but if
you generated samples already those
samples had disease such a and if it's
multiple stacks of flows then you also
have the some the Z's in between and
every every every block in between and
so if you have both the Z's and the A's
then you can train your if very fast
uh so Best of Both Worlds um train AF
fast then sample from the AF keepy
activations
specifically disease if it's just a one
one stack thing is just you keep disease
if it's multiple blocks you might keep
the ones in between and then um you can
train um fast and Sample
fast um naively if you have an autog of
flow or inverse autog of flow flow this
ends up being a very deep Network
because you need to First generate Z1
then Z2 then Z3 even just one flow block
can be very deep but um and You' have a
ridiculous number of parameters but of
course you can do parameter sharing just
like we did with autoaggressive models
you set up the same neural network to do
these mappings um and that way using an
RNN using masking um you can get a
reasonably sized Network to do this for
you
okay what else can we do autoaggressive
is clearly one way to go it's given some
good results
um the the thing that kind of put flows
on the mapd was the real MVP paper
um and they are going to flow with
Transformations that do many variables
at the same time many exess to many Z's
at the same time in one invertible
mapping um just like have to preserve
the probability mass for each interval
going from X to Z for 1D we need to now
preserve the probability mass for each
volume around a certain X see where that
volume essentially maps to in Z space
make sure the same amount of probability
Mass lives in that volume and so to
compensate for that there's this
compensation term now determinant of the
Jacobian matrix DZ
DX if it's 1D this Matrix is just a 1 by
one Matrix is DZ DX that's it it's the
same thing if it's a
diagonal um situation where um
effectively every gets mapped
independently then the determinant is
just a product of the entries on a
diagonal and so it's again just like a
rescaling along each axis the axis X1 to
Z1 X2 to Z2 X3 to Z3 and so forth so for
1D and diagonal it's easy to understand
that this is the correct thing to do how
do we know it's correct for arbitrary
the way I like to think of it is that
any kind of square Matrix that goes from
X to Z um so let's say I have because
locally this is all linear so that's
what we look at if I have z = a * X I
can also say equals U Sigma V transpose
X singular value decomposition
this is just a rotation of xace I don't
need to worry about volume preservation
everything stays the same I'm just
rotating things everything's contained
um this is a rotation at the end or I
could even move it to the other side
again nothing to worry about about the
probability Mass preservation everything
is happening
here um and so only thing I need to
worry about is the middle one and I just
need to take the product of the elements
on the
diagonal
well if I take the product of the
diagonal entries it only has diagonal
entries of Sigma that is the same as the
determinant of a is the same thing um
and so maybe that's how you're going to
compute that determinant maybe you
compute it in a different way we haven't
talked about how we get that determinant
but um intuition wise this is why the
determinant make sense um in the right
coordinate space everything is just
diagonal anyway is the product of the
diagonal elements is what you
need okay um so our change of variable
formula P Theta X is p of f Theta of X
which is z and then multiply with
determinant determinant by the way
there's absolute values around this to
make sure that it's a positive number we
multiply with um that was also true
before you also have to look at the you
don't want to end up with negative
densities and this then becomes a
training
objective so the requirement if we map a
vector of x's into a vector of Z's is
that that mapping is invertible so F
Theta has to be invertible to go back
from Z to
X that might put some constraints on it
we'll talk about that an additional
requirement now determinant must be easy
to calculate because if we can't
calculate this determinant easily then
we have a very expensive training
process because we'll need access to
that determinant to do our training okay
so you're going to want to start
thinking about okay what kind of
mappings have you know where the all the
local linear approximations have
convenient um determinants to
compute by the way if the determinant is
not easy to compute it's still a flow is
just a flow that you can't really train
you have no computational approach to
train it and the terminants in general
are actually very expensive to compute
um so for a general Matrix um kind of
the worst case scenario is essentially
that you need to do something equivalent
roughly to the SVD which is a quite a
bit of work to then multiply the
diagonal elements
together um you don't have to do exactly
that um it turns out that if a matrix
is lower triangular everything above the
diagonal is zero it's also just the
product of the diagonal elements and so
that's kind of what we'll be thinking
about determin that's easy to compute
means the upper triangle is all zeros um
or more than that is all zeros um so
anything that has that property will be
convenient to work with
um so you'll see that pop up a
lot remember that even though we're
constrained for each mapping to make it
convenient and invertible and easy
determinant we can stack them together
and we already saw with autog of flows
allows us to change the ordering along
the stack and be more expressive than
the other res of models from last time
even though within each stack we're a
bit more constrained question here yeah
so I understand toity in your matrix
it's a matrix upper or lower triang how
can you guarantee that will happen so
you can easily get this determined so it
doesn't become too computationally
expensive or that you don't end up with
you know something that has a
singular yeah it's a good question how
do we ensure that this properties hold
and that's exactly what we'll talk about
for the next several slides so it's
perfect question it's not easy I mean
some people have figured out some ways
to do it but it's still restrictive in
terms of what you can and cannot
do question
here
because you're dealing with essentially
no dimensionality reduction at all yeah
it's just
like I think it's a good question right
given you are constrained in what you
can
express is it the case that by making
the chain long enough you still have
full expressivity maybe maybe not I
don't know that's an interesting
question and then the question from
there then becomes if the chain is very
long how long does it really have to be
and does it become impractical both in
terms of compute but possibly in terms
of gradients propagating because the
deeper a network the more trouble you
have with gradients propagating well so
there could be additional considerations
like that yeah I don't have a precise
answer but I'm just rephrasing your
question as indeed a great
question
so what can we do we can do apine flows
pretty simple just linear um linear
connection between x and z um so one
block would just be xal a z plus b or
zal ax plus b depending how you set it
up the Jacobian is a or a inverse
depending on which direction you set it
up you need to calculate DET termin of a
so maybe a should be lower triangular to
make that easy and that's the maximum
expressiveness in some sense that that
you get um without becoming very
expensive to deal
with elementwise flows you could
essentially make the functions as a
whole just elementwise
calculations so each element gets
transformed on its own to the next layer
whoops table came apart um careful that
it doesn't drop
you
fixed
um maybe not for leaning
though there's more table space here to
lean against
um now you might say why would diagonal
be a great thing to use well diagonal on
its own you kind of lose everything
about it being a high dimensional data
set where you have patterns that are
connecting the dimensions but maybe you
have a layer that is aine Follow by a
layer that's diagonal which introduces
some nonlinearities and then you go
again aine and so forth so that's the
idea
here the nice real MVP line of work
essentially can think of it as almost
like a block version of Auto regressive
so it
says my first half of Z variables I just
pass on the X's do nothing with
them in principle you could maybe put
something else there but for Simplicity
here for this one layer you can have
many of these stack together but this
one you just pass it on and then the
second half you're allowed to process
that first half of
X whichever way you want because you'll
have it available when you go inverse so
you turn it into in this case um I think
this dot in this case is typically an
element wise product so you turn it into
an L you know essentially a diagonal
matrix is the way to think of it but you
could do anything you want nonlinearity
with the first half of the AIS when you
do this and then multiply it element
twice with the second half so you can
get a pretty nonlinear transformation of
your variables this way um and it's easy
to invert because once you have the Z's
it's very easy to get back to the first
half of the axis once you have the first
half of the AIS you can compute this
once you have this here which is just a
a diagonal multiplied in you can just
solve to um to get the um other X's out
um by essentially bring this to the
other side and then divide by this and
you're good to
go if you spell it out what it comes
down to is the Jacobian matrix you just
pass things on in the first half that's
a jacoban that's identity then the way
the first half of the variables
influences the second half
um is
um through this
thing over here which is pretty
complicated but it lands over
here and then the way the second half
influences itself
is by just multiplying in this so it's
pretty simple just that diagonal over
there so what we see is that um you just
have a diagonal take the product of the
diagonal everything above is zeros and
you can very efficiently compute the
determinant real MVP actually got some
pretty good
um results the key thing is that the
coupling layers can really allow you to
put anything kind of neural net on those
coupling axes from first half to second
half remember in these flow models when
you stack them together when each
component is a flow the Stacked version
sequence together is still a flow so
first half second half doesn't have to
stay the same for the next one you go
with a different ordering next one you
go with yet a different ordering so it's
not that there is this specific ordering
effect that is going to um have to be
persisting throughout the entire
calculation here are some faces
generated by this is 2017 generative
models wer in all that good yet very
promising um faces I think this is
bedrooms this is um buildings and then I
guess this is outdoor scenes of some
type or other um pretty good for that
time there are some details in goes a 32
by 32 by the number of channels which is
three RGB image um and then there's a
question how do you order
these
variables essentially uh the the
variables so that you can do this
conditioning in more complicated ways
what's the first half what's the second
half and um this is the the layout in
terms of um words but essentially in
picture some of the conditioning um does
checkerboard pattern where you
alternate so one and five and four and
eight are in the first half and then two
2 6 3 and seven are in the second half
that feels a lot like a diffusion model
where you're getting some sense a
subsampled version first and then you
work your way to get a higher resolution
version um other ones can in principle
go top down left right and so forth it's
not as as common and then at some point
you effectively start turning these
things into channels you just give them
meaning you just say okay now I think of
what came out of this as one of the
channels that lives over here and then
you can run over the image that's a
lower resolution image but again it's
it's only imagination of how you group
variables but it's a way to give
structure to it where you essentially
saying there's now a channel Dimension
that represents the upper left right or
upper upper left corner and then upper
right corner bottom left corner bottom
right corner you cannot reduce the
dimensionality because that's not
invertible so anytime you reduce let's
say a factor two your channels go up by
a factor two or 2x two reduction 4X
channel in increase um you can also do
these things within you know one
location just do something there that's
very close to the element twice forward
running that's also going to be a pretty
uh cheap Jacobian uh to to have the
determinant
for um good versus bad partitioning so
checkerboard Channel squeeze channel on
squeeze checkerboard that gives you this
which is pretty decent this is like top
half bottom half left half that doesn't
really give the effects you're looking
for
um in some sense it seems mag magical
right that you can do this you can
switch the ordering everywhere but it it
kind of somehow is inspired by Bas Nets
but every block is like a Bas net and
then it could be a different structure
on the next
block
um I think I want to to skip the slide
but the pdf version retained everything
um so real
MVP and autog of models those are the
two main ideas that had worked well for
flows but none of it had worked super
well then the glow flow Plus+ and F
papers came about that made things work
as well as the best models of other
types at the time
yes
so you're talking about this slide here
right
yeah so sampling we need to go from Z to
X for the first half as as you said of
course it's identity mapping so trivial
for the second half you then plug this
in here which gives you s Theta
s Theta is a diagonal matrix by the way
so it's very easy to deal with so this
is essentially
just D over2 equations one equation
for you know each variable and you can
just directly solve it for each of the
variables right because it'll look
essentially like this these are the
disting here is that equal to then I'll
draw it as a diagonal
Matrix the s's are here and this is s
this is X that you're solving for this
is z and this is plus T which is also
known so you're just solving this pretty
simple linear system for
x by the way some things in the
inversion that I didn't talk about can
sometimes be a little tricky um because
imagine you're you're using a cumulative
density function somewhere along the way
in the elementwise layers and you're
using a you know mixture of logistics or
something it turns out that the forward
path through mixture of logistics is
quite straightforward but then the
backward pass um you might have to do
more work so some some functions are
invertible but require a bit of work but
if the function is just one dimensional
sometimes you're willing to pay the
price because if
it's invert a one dimensional invert
function you can always do it by
bisection search you kind of just keep
you say okay I'm going to guess the X
I'm going to get is going to be
somewhere in this interval and I just
keep bisecting till I find the one that
actually lands corresponding to the Z
that I
sampled but once you're higher
dimensional you can't do bisection
search so you need to really structure
it to make sure the inverse is
efficient couple questions yeah has
anybody tried random
partioning good question
um my hunches people tried it it didn't
work very well but I can't give you hard
facts on
that
um now it might work better than some
very poorly chosen partitioning
orderings um but I think the notion of
some sense doing local
calculations and from there generating a
deeper Channel Dimension and working
your way through in the way that
confidence tend to organize how
information gets processed and um
somehow put together in a more
meaningful way than the original input
that I think has given the best uh
results
yes
yeah you I mean essentially do yeah R
run run multiple I guess training runs
and then try to find which order rings
tend to work better and then learn a
model for that I haven't seen people do
that
no so as I said um glow flow Plus+ f are
the ones that really made um flow models
work as well as the other best um
Methods at the
time by the way the the flow plus plus
paper is one we did here at Berkeley
Jonathan H did that one in 2019 and then
in 2020 he did diffusion models and then
he made his flow Plus+ paper a little
obsolete I guess for time being um
because then the fusion models took over
um but you know you don't noce things
ahead of time
so when we think
about the couple
transformation between x and z and this
is looking in in the opposite direction
um you somehow have this like ordering
aspect to it it could be with blocks it
could be more refined orderings uh to
make sure things are
invertible um what you can do and what's
done in BIOS in the flow Plus+ paper is
to use more complex nonlinear coupling
layers so after you have that linear
transformation um you might use cdfs and
inverse cdfs for mixture of gion or
Logistics giving you more than what you
got out of what was used before um
there's not a paper paper neural
importance sampling they used piecewise
linear and quadratic functions that also
helped so essentially putting more in
the coupling layers was one thing we
did
so mixture of
logistics um and then self attention
right the component that can do anything
where you process something to then
multiply it into the other variables the
part where you can do any neural network
transformation um we're the first ones
to introduce self attention into that
that also helped quite a bit and so what
you see here
is the full model we had achieves 3.65
bits per dim that's a compression level
that was best among the things we tried
if we remove the self attenion from the
neural net we do worse it matters
clearly if we go to Aline coupling
rather than mixture of logistics we do
worse um and if we don't do the
dequantization which I'll talk about
soon we do a lot worse um so that was
some the the worst thing if you didn't
do it um but all three of these really
mattered to get the best possible
results there a question somewhere
yes go
back sure
sure
yep but I guess with some of these
things
con I know that we're talking so you
have
represent
transing their
distrib where it's not the it but it's
theam that describe theb over those
items um so when we're talking about
theun the flow functions that we're
learning I'm imagining that the function
take not the item itself but theam that
descri item I
guess I that perspective when we
describe like
distrib talk so gu that in mind you know
what goes into these functions are theam
the distrib
and when you have these equations are
you
restricting like the first to
yeah so it's a good question how to and
there's two ways to think about the flow
models that you're highlighting one way
to think of it is that in some sense we
are choosing parameters of a
distribution over X but in a very
special way um uh but in the case where
we use a CDF as our
flow we are doing the exact equivalent
of that um and so that's one view on it
if we don't use a CDF as our flow it's
not so easy to see that parallel and so
for the more General version it's easier
to think of it as just I need an
invertible transformation that I can
efficiently
compute and it doesn't need to be a CDF
it could be but it doesn't need to be
and so in that case there is no such
direct counterpart of just thinking of
as parameters of a distribution um and
it probably makes it easier to think of
these models that way um because now
you're just thinking okay all I'm doing
is an invertible transformation one
space to another space and that's
it by the way I think flow models are
kind of the most difficult models to
wrap your head around at least for me um
so that might also be why it's harder to
make progress on them because it's just
I mean the first time I saw any of this
I was just like my reaction was none of
this makes sense like are you sure they
actually did what they described because
it's so complex is some of little
subtleties going on that it was hard to
even trust that this thing was actually
real um after you know teaching it
multiple times even coming back to it
last week reworking myself fully into it
took me like a week to fully convince
myself that this is real this is
actually indeed correct how it works so
I'm not not surprised a lot of questions
pop up um I feel like if I'd been in
class and see this for the first time
I'd have like a question every minute or
I'd have no questions because I have no
clue what's going on would be one or the
other um so yeah don't hesitate to to
ask questions um same for other lectures
but especially here I think it's uh it's
a pretty complicated thing to wrap your
your head
around so then um Dirk kingma and um I
think it was profa
um at open AI did another version of
this called glow and one of the big
things they introduced was invertible
one by one convolutions if you're uh
familiar with com Nets you know that
they start with just kind of let's say
3x3 or a 5x5 7 by seven but then you get
channel Dimension starts increasing and
often you just do effectively a a
mapping just within one pixel which is
now a high Channel Dimension pixel
and so a big thing they introduced is to
parameterize invertible of these one by
one convolutions to really process
what's locally happening in an
interesting way much larger scale
training the way they architected it
they could train at a much larger scale
and these results became like real like
okay now it's real faces of of real
people uh pretty amazing there's an
interpretation of flows as a continuous
thing rather than discreete uh discrete
blocks after each other it's just like a
continuous uh flow um with continuous
Flows In Time this is continuous in time
um invertibility is essentially
guaranteed because locally um you can
invert it's a benefit um I don't think
it's really taken off but there might be
something
there let me let me show you some of the
glow results so one thing I talked about
is that flow models can give a embedding
space the Z space and it's nice to check
how good is it um by the way
autoaggressive models did not give us a
zspace last lecture right here on the
left is a original image on the all the
way on the right is an original image so
this is original this is original they
both get mapped to their
Z's then an interpolation happens in
zspace and the corresponding samples get
generated and that's how the
intermediate faces get U I guess created
now what are we looking for here with a
bad model we would see a pixel level
interpolation effectively where the
faces in between just look like an
overlay of the two faces rather than a
face that in some way is still a real
face but something in between what we
see here is real faces that are some
combination of the two and that's what
we're hoping for so that means this
model trained well in terms of getting
good embeddings same here to extremes
are Originals what's in between is the
same process for interpolation and same
thing over
here then you can also control the
attributes so how do you do that let's
say I want to control how much so in
this case the originals are the ones in
the middle in each
case and then we want to have a slider
make this person smile more or less BL
hair or darker hair younger or older and
so forth how do you do that um after you
train your model you take a bunch of
training data you embedded but you
partition your training data you have
one partition of training data where you
say this is older faces another
partition you say this is younger faces
you take the embeddings from both sides
take the average from both sides take
the difference between the two averages
and that represents a direction to go
from young to old or old to Young and so
that's how this is done um so this
requires some label data in some sense
right you're effectively for some data
saying these are older these are younger
these are more blonde less blonde and so
forth but it's not a detailed labeling
and the labels are not used during
training it's just used after the fact
after you train your model we can see
that the embedding space has nice
alignment with uh some of these ideas
that we like to have control over maybe
when we generate faces or other
things
[Music]
um yeah this is some food for thought um
but in some
sense if you look at the
logistic logistic before the sampling
happens in your discrete models um you
can think of that as still being
continuous in our discrete
autoaggressive models you can think of
them as maybe also being invertible from
the logistic representation back to
where you you came from um I don't think
that's really used by anyone but if you
are you know try to think about
connections between the two it's
something to keep in
mind okay last piece dequantization
this is from our flow Plus+ paper
um this is just a like a an example of
course this is not a large scale image
training but an example of a
distribution that is affective ly
discreet right but pixels are also
discret they're numbers from 0 to 255
and none of them are anything but an
integer if you literally take your data
so if we've modeled them as continuous
variables they're essentially densities
that are extremely peaked at very
specific locations if you train what
will happen is something like what you
see in the middle um it'll learn that
there are Peaks they'll have found some
Peaks and put enormous Mass on a few of
these Peaks and largely ignore the
others that it didn't
find it doesn't completely ignore the
others there's a non-zero density so
it's not like he gets a negative
Infinity score on the others but it
really propels some of them up
dramatically get ideally you could get
to a positive Infinity score if you
really compress everything into a zero
width interval you can get infinity and
get a log of infinity and get a really
high score so that's what's happening
there you can see the training score the
negative log loss is getting better and
better and better it is very happy with
the situation but we're not getting the
distribution fit that we're hoping
for so this happens with pixels
um what what can we do instead um we
know that the density really is about
modeling the mass in an
interval we need to make sure it retains
that
meaning and there's a complicated
derivation you can do but essentially
the idea is that when you have your data
you should put noise on it if a pixel
value is 125 you should put noise on it
so it lands between
124.5 and
125.5 and re resample it every time you
use it do that for all of them what does
that do it removes those Peaks it
Smooths out your original data
distribution into one that is actually
your density and now you have no
trouble um let me see yeah now you might
say that feels like a hack um it it
seems intuitively correct but it feels a
bit hacky to start you can
derive um effectively um a Bound for
this you can you can say that if what
I'm really modeling is the probability
of Landing in an interval and my data
just happens to be in certain locations
but I allocate the probability of the
interval to it which means I have to do
an integral over my continuous density
which is a bit annoying to have to do
but if I were to do that every
time and I then bound it by instead
putting noise on the samples there's a
close connection between the two it's
not exactly the same but um if I put the
right noise on the samples it turns out
it can be a a tide bound and so what we
did in the flow Plus+ paper we actually
also trained it so instead of sampling
uniform 0.5 plus 0.5 we trained a model
to decide how much mass should shift
lower versus higher in that length one
interval um the default not learning
would be uniform and learning would make
it more precise might say why why why
does learning make sense well think
about it if your data distribution looks
something like
this right then maybe it makes sense to
think that it actually looks
more like this right and that in this
interval over here there's a slope to it
it's not uniform and that's effectively
what you capture when you learn that
what we what is called dequantization
you say the original data was probably
continuous but it was sampled rounded
onto these quantized values and from
everything I'm learning I now think that
the original data came from this
distribution not uniform around it and
I'm going to resample it using this
distribution rather than
uniform um
flow and discreete data with
dequantization that's what we looked at
earlier for another example we saw it
had this weird you know Peaks popping up
when we do the proper dequantization
doesn't happen the training loss looks
much cleaner so that's um what we have
now so strong relationship to
compression um when you compress
continuous data you actually in the end
do need to have a meaning of
discretization Because if you think
about continuous data how can you
compress continuous data one number has
infinite information in it in principle
it just keeps going a real number so you
need to
effectively if you want to formalize
this all in terms of
discrete actual compressible you know
things you can quantify as how many bits
you're going to send and we'll talk
about compression towards the end of of
uh the
semester so what are some possible
future directions remember these are
the goals fast sampling fast inference
fast training good samples good
compression flows seem to allow us to
achieve some maybe all of these criteria
but not all equally well it address it
it pays attention to all of them whereas
the aive model didn't really think about
embeddings slend representations so
that's the compression part here um
didn't really think about those things
but flows do um it's still an open
question um how to design each
individual flow block and how to compose
them into something that is going to
work really really
well these are my thoughts at the bottom
some requirements that might pose
permanent challenges like you could
either agree with those and then decide
I'm not going to work on Flow models
because I think these are kind of
problematic or you can say well that's
what everybody thinks but actually
they're probably wrong
and I don't think it's so insurmountable
I'm going to write a cool paper that
shows that they can do really well
because that can work around this
dimensionality
preserving now I should add a little
color to that the way people have
achieved dimensionality reduction in
flows is you do your
flow and then at some point after some
blocks of flow for half of your
variables you decide that you stop
flowing them you like you keep using
identity that don't interact with
anything you just stop flowing them
and then the others keep going you do
that again a bit later again a bit later
what does that do well that means that
the ones that still end up all the way
at the end they're the chor
representation of your image let's say
and then the ones that join again later
only they're finer and then even even
later even finer so you then hope that
the ones that drop out the earliest
learn to represent the fine grain
details and the one that stays stick
around the longest you hope they learn
to represent the big picture sense of
what's in the image
um you know that's how it's done it
again it's a very specific way of of
doing it which feels not as flexible as
what some other models do they just say
oh I'm going to you know apply a layer
where I reduce the dimensionality a
learned way of redution dimensionality
and then I continue with lower
Dimensions invertibility it's nice we
you can get samples out in a
deterministic way once you sample your Z
you know what you're getting um but
everything we talked about seems to be
the invertibility and the cheap
determinant requirement essentially told
us this is all you get to do you don't
get to do anything but this and this
type of layer um so clearly it's putting
a lot of constraints on what we're
putting in um maybe it's fine maybe the
invertibility is such a great thing for
some reason to have that you willing to
pay that price maybe not um I think in
an era where everything is about scaling
and up as easily as possible and be as
expressive as possible I think we still
need to see a breakthrough in flows that
is as expressive as let's say a
Transformer model right if you come up
with the counterpart of that something
that absorbs all single linear data the
way a Transformer does while being
invertible in the sense of flow models
well then all of a sudden probably flow
models will give really good results
compared to what we have today and then
you'll scale them up even more even
better results but right now that's not
the the case we don't know that yet in
fact if you look at the homework sequel
four years ago four homeworks this year
four homeworks three homeworks are in
the same topic though they're quite
dramatically revised because the topics
have evolved but the flow homework we've
taken out in favor of a diffusion
homework in this cycle because the
diffusion models are just much more
widely used today compared to flow
models let's see if I have I think that
might be the last slide but let me
check oh that's a bibliography so if
you again I think you know this is what
research is about you you take a bad and
you have a believe that something might
or might not be promising if you want to
dive deeper I would suggest starting
with these two survey papers um get a
general overview of what's been done not
been done as you see this is until 2019
2021 but in my literature search leading
up to this class I didn't find really
any works that have happened since then
that got a lot of follow on so I did a
search where I would look at okay who is
citing the papers that are listed you
like who is citing the real MVP paper
because you got to cite it if you write
a good flow paper it must be cited so I
go to Google Scholar say okay who's
cting real MVP among the ones who site
real MVP which ones have more citations
meaning that the work is likely you know
important and people are paying
attention and follow on and
literally there was nothing that popped
out with a high citation count as oh we
need to go look at this and incorporate
it into lecture all the high citation
effectively were the ones already on
this slide and then these were the two
most highly cited ones of the 2020s um
which if there were a real breakthrough
there would be another paper that is um
I mean these are probably cited about a
thousand times or something but the
diffusion paper that we wrote is cited
like six 7,000 times and it's from the
same year so nothing of the same type
has happened in the intervening time
again could be an opportunity I don't
want to say you can find something some
gem there that you discover but right
now it's not looking as promising
um let's take uh one or two more
questions and then I'll have office
hours after so we resolve a lot of other
questions in office hour let's start
there yeah when you use do you lose
um when you use quantization do you lose
the
invertibility you can round back at the
end so in that sense I don't think you
you lose it because essentially you're
adding noise but it's within an interval
and so as you work through it when you
work your way back as the network is
invertible you land back within the
correct
interval now you could argue that maybe
you land on something even better in
that you have actually even in the but
maybe your computer screen cannot
represent it because you can't add more
you know bits to your to your pixel
values but maybe the dequantization
actually made it more precise than you
would have gotten otherwise but you have
to round back onto uh the bits that you
have to represent your
image
um so
the way the dequantization is done it's
it's forced to be within an interval
that keeps you where the center of that
interval and also the Bounder say that
there's nothing else there so it's not
you can't add gaussian noise you just
add noise within the interval and since
you can't leave the interval you land
back into
it yeah um it seems like if you're going
to pay the price of like those three
things there has to be some advantage
over like a for you to use it do you
have any intuition for what those
advantages might be if we like continue
research yeah
so one of the challenges with vaes has
been historically that um we'll talk
more about the next lecture um that the
latent space you end up in it's also
continuous lat in space and that that
space if you sample from that space
very often when you map back out you
decode you end up with something that's
not so meaningful and so what does that
mean is that you need a better model of
that latent space and so the progress in
vaes in the last few years has all been
around training an other Distribution on
top of your vae to model the
distribution in the latent space and
then when you use that learn
distribution to sample from you are on
distribution in are generating good
samples flow models might have less of
that challenge because the distribution
in the end is forced to be very simple
and you're forcing it on to that um so
the samples might naturally you know or
sampling from the zspace is better
behaved because you forced it to be a
simple clean space
um and the invertibility I think ensures
that no funny things happen as you work
your way back
um so that's one thing but then people
have made progress on um
on training the models inside the latent
space of the vae to get better results
there um so I don't know Wilson Phil you
have any thoughts on where where the
invertibility flow
models could pay
off not
really that's an
answer yeah nothing else I think like
Oneal Advantage like there's some
specific structure like maybe like you
have some
scientific whatever application where it
be nice to have
some yeah I think one of the things that
you also have as a benefit but it's more
resolved with models too is that because
of the invertibility you don't get the
collapse that you might get sometimes
with other models that used to be
popular like ganss you're kind of forced
to cover the whole distribution that's
kind of true for every likelihood model
as long as you train a likelihood model
you have to keep covering the entire
distribution of your training data
because otherwise you get a very bad
score um that's kind of general property
of all the likelihood
models yeah can I can we go back to the
apping sure I find
coupling my question
is
okay scaling term that's called the
ad so the a term here is the one that
can be an arbitrary neural networ
calculation depending on the parent
variables of the variable XI so you IGN
this so it's going to be addition
between two terms yes and it look to me
exactly like res
so you you you yeah you can definitely
construct skip Connections in here if
you want to that's a good observation
skip connections are part of what you
can represent no problem yeah yeah
however
we okay let let's take a what we get is
the determinant of this function is
one yeah just to be explicit if I want
to make it into a skip connection I
would add a plus Z here right that's all
I have to do okay the a term becomes one
let's say so we don't predict that one
by default and this look like res
because you have C some add looks like a
reset except that your what you
calculate can only depend on the
essentially the parents of that variable
so anything that comes ahead so it
starts looking a lot like a regular
autoaggressive model in some sense um
but in continuous space now
yeah it also applies to Res the parent
is the previous correct and in this case
probably if you use
like that is the which looks to me like
very res yeah there's strong connections
there I agree res has super I mean this
powerful architecture
MH but so can I say that this
architecture while being invertable also
powerful
I mean it is pretty powerful given you
know the results you saw with the
interpolation and the face generation so
it's not that it's not can't do anything
it's just it's still seemingly more
restrictive than other
architectures I don't get the
restrictive part I mean because I I
cannot see too much difference between
that equation and the resent equation MH
they should be
equally try it try it see see if you
look at the details of the resonet
architectures used today if they really
are invertible because I think they
often will essentially they will
squeeze the dimensionality in various
places they will do projections as they
work their way through now maybe you can
work around that maybe you can set up
some kind of complicated unit um and
then that way effectively get the
information back um it might be worth
worth thinking
about let me take three more questions
one two three in class and then
everything else we'll do after class
yeah
isn't the only difference the term when
you're optimizing models you
have well definitely it's a big
difference whether you optimize for
classification or something else do you
could in a resonant in principle use it
to optimize for reconstruction or other
things um I mean more like there's that
ter got it got it
that's in terms of the way it's trained
the determinant term is definitely
affecting the training very directly
it's a dimensionality preserving term
which maybe comes down to the question
whether you want that or not right do
you want dimensionality preservation not
fality like volume probability Mass
preservation um as you process things or
do you think some should be more
compressed together and another things
should be spread out more than they are
in the original data inherently that's a
con
correct I think there were two more
questions we're going to do
yes like you know Z2 depend on Z1 Z3 on
the other Z Etc or do you just like
sample yeah that's a good question that
depends on uh the so the question is can
you sample your z's independently and
then start generating the AIS in in case
of an inverse aive flow All In Parallel
right so it's not just like parall I
mean that but also like not even paraliz
as far as interdependence between
different parts got it yeah so then the
question becomes what distribution do
you want to use to represent the Z's
right and in your sequence of blocks as
you work through the next layer of Z's
next layer of Z's you're not doing
anything you you just work your way
through and you work your way back but
at the very very end you actually put a
density on Z's and that one you have to
make a choice you could decide to choose
a density over Z that is much more
complex you could just like people are
doing with Vees right now when they
train Vees there's a
very like intricate distribution being
modeled on the latent space in fact
latent diffusion in some sense that's
exactly that it's like a very
complicated train model on the latent
space you can in principle do the same
thing here I could have a normalizing
flow and then train essentially a latent
diffusion model on the final Z's to get
a much more expressive set of Z's and
then maybe you can have a much more
expressive model with this flow model
right so you can do the same thing there
in which case sampling disease will be
different from just sampling them
independently from a gaussian a lot of
the work that was
done with flow models so far the zspace
tends to be very simple it's just a
gaussian independent gaussian and you
just sample from that um and in
principle that maybe that should be
enough but maybe it's not enough maybe
the right model says Hey for that to be
enough you need such a deep model it's
not practically it's too intense
competition the gradients don't
propagate well enough I like the notion
of a flow model for some of the modeling
of the data but at the end I should use
a different model like a latent
diffusion model to model disease and
that way the combination can give me
better results it's very
possible okay last
one this but can you repeat how can we
do conditional generation or guide the
sampling
process yeah
so in any of these models as you look at
let's say any of these parameterized
parts um if you were conditioning which
wasn't really done as much at the time
it became more popular in 2020 2021 um
you can just have the neural net that
encodes this also condition on any kind
of embeddings or other information uh
another image some text condition on it
right there um no
problem all right thank you see you next
week